[Música]
kiev urge a los civiles a evacuar las
zonas del este y el sur de ucrania el
principal campo de batalla de lo que
moscú llama la nueva fase de la guerra
en la región de donets en la ciudad de
crema torch donde murieron más de 50
personas en un ataque ruso que moscú
niega en la estación de tren algunos
deciden quedarse a pesar de las alertas
de intensificación de la ofensiva rusa
en el flanco oriental
wheeler ha habido ha habido bombardeos
es realmente una pena porque tenemos una
ciudad tan bonita
que esperamos que no haya más bombardeos
sobre crematorio depositamos mucha
esperanza en nuestros soldados ucrania
ganará 100% ganará
otros deciden abandonar su hogar a
tiempo
tengo miedo que esto se convierta en
mariupol no quiero que mi perro se quede
aquí todos los veterinarios están
cerrados
según las autoridades ucranianas a
mariupol le quedan días sino horas para
caer en manos rusas una vez tomada la
estratégica ciudad portuaria del mar
negro
las fuerzas de moscú podrán redirigir
más efectivos hacia la ofensiva del
donbass y además tendrán conexión
directa entre la anexada crimea y los
territorios que controlan en el este del
país
así se baila
un ataque ruso es de esperar pero los
nuestros no se rendirán los rusos no se
quedarán aquí mucho tiempo la verdad ya
basta de todo esto honestamente tengo
suficiente
el ejército de ucrania recibe armamento
pesado de los aliados occidentales
sin embargo las tropas rusas continúan
superando en número a las ucranianas y
las negociaciones entre kiev y moscú
están en punto muerto